[Musique]
le marché immobilier continue de
ralentir au canada dans la région de
toronto surtout le nombre de
transactions a chuté de 41% au mois de
juin comparativement à la même période
l'an dernier le prix moyen de vente
reste très élevé un million cent
quarante six mille dollars c'est en
hausse de 5,3 pour cent sur un an mais
le recul des prix amorcé au printemps se
poursuit on a une baisse de 5 et demi
pour cent sur un seul mois de son côté
le ralentissement à montréal est un peu
moins marquée dans la grande région le
nombre de transactions a baissé de 11%
depuis un an le prix médian pour les
maisons unifamiliales est en hausse de
12% sur un an 570 mille dollars et
depuis un mois le prix a baissé
d'environ 1% par ailleurs la société
canadienne d'hypothèques et de logement
schl a publié son rapport semestriel sur
les prêts hypothécaires le secteur des
prêts hypothécaires est notre invité
tania bourassa au chaud un spécialiste
de principal de recherche de
l'habitation pour la schl est là pour
nous en parler bonsoir merci d'être là
on est ce que vous êtes étonnés d'abord
par les chiffres qu'on vient d'entendre
ce ralentissement un recul des prix
c'est une tendance que vous observez
c'est effectivement une tendance qu'on
observe en fait quand on regarde du côté
de l'endettement des ménages on regarde
en 2021 et même en 2022 on voyait que la
dette des ménages
s'accélérait beaucoup donc ça continue
de crottes accéléré et même dans les
premiers mois de 2000 22 aucune dette
des ménages qui est élevée c'est sûr
qu'avec des taux d'intérêt qui augmente
et on peut s'attendre à un certain
ralentissement notamment du côté du
marché des prix peut-être laissé
particulier votre rapport porte
spécifiquement sur les prêts
hypothécaires vous avez parlé
d'endettement endettement hypothécaires
qui d'ailleurs toujours en croissance et
qui s'accélère selon votre rapport mais
l'impression que c'est un peu
contradictoire avec le ralentissement
des transactions sur le marché va en
fait c'est vraiment des données qui date
de 2021 et 2022 jusqu'en mars donc on
peut s'attendre à peut-être une tendance
qui va changer quelque peu au cours des
prochains mois mais effectivement on a
un niveau de dette qui a augmenté
beaucoup les taux d'intérêt étant très
bas
il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de non
seulement de prêts hypothécaires pour
des propriétés pour la cette propriété
mais aussi pour des refinancements et en
fait choses intéressantes ou ce titre la
question des taux d'intérêt donc vous
vous souviendrez que en 2021 la deuxième
partie de l'année il y avait un escompte
quand même assez grand entre les taux
variables oui les taux fixes et donc en
fait une proportion majoritaire des
canadiens a opté pour un tour variable
qui en fait est intéressant parce que
historiquement parlant dans en fait
c'est particulier je vous dirais parce
que dans le contexte actuel on est très
sensibilisé au fait que les banques les
banques centrales vont augmenter les
taux directeurs ça va faire monter le
taux variable on le sait qu'il veut
monter et malgré tout dans votre rapport
on apprend ainsi plus de la majorité et
le cc 53 % des canadiens qui ont opté
pour un taux variable sachant tout de
même qu'il va augmenter donc c'est là
l'écart entre le taux variable et le
taux fixe qui justifie selon vous c'est
exact encore une fois les données
demeurent jusqu'en mars avril donc on
peut s'attendre peut-être un changement
de tendance ou du moins une proportion
plus petite de gens qui vont opter pour
un taux variable
ceci dit quand on regarde le stock de
prêts hypothécaires au canada c'était
vraiment trois canadiens sur quatre qui
ont encore un taux fixe donc c'est sûr
que dans un contexte où les taux
d'intérêt vont augmenter
c'est sûr que c'était les canadiens qui
ont un taux variable que là la pression
reste à faire sentir plus rapidement que
du côté des taux fixes moyens et avec
l'inflation est la hausse des taux
d'intérêt la préoccupation est
évidemment quand on se penche sur le
marché hypothécaire c'est tous ces gens
là seront ils en mesure de rembourser
leur dette c'est effectivement une
question intéressante il ya plusieurs
facteurs par contre à considérer donc
d'une part et comme je mentionnais la
majorité des canadiens ont un taux fixe
cinq ans donc c'est vraiment au moment
du renouvellement que le taux d'intérêt
va vraiment avoir un impact puis vous
vous souviendrez peut-être aussi du
morgen reste est le stress tests est
frustré ce test en 2018 qui est en fait
une simulation de crise donc on est
vraiment venu s'assurer que tous les
dossiers par très un taux d'intérêt plus
élevé que celui qui était accordé donc
cette réglementation était vraiment
mises en place pour permettre pour
stature et finalement que les canadiens
vont être en mesure de faire leurs
paiements et autre fait intéressant
c'est qu'au canada on a ce qu'on appelle
les prêts hypothécaires pleinement
garantis donc en fait un prêteur dans
une situation où l'emprunteur ne pouvait
pas payer est dans une situation extrême
où la propriété valait moins que le prêt
hypothécaire est bien le traiteur
pourrait aller saisir d'autres actifs et
en fait c'est ce qui explique pourquoi
il ya une différence aussi marqué du
côté des taux de délinquance au canada
que aux états unis où ils sont beaucoup
plus élevés parce que dans une situation
comme ça eh bien on pourrait
laisser les clés finalement c'est en
avant mais c'est particulier parce que
non seulement les taux de défaut de
paiement sont très bas plus bas au
canada ou aux états unis mais ils
continuent de reculer comment on
l'expliquer mais selon les dernières
données les canadiens sont en mesure de
faire leurs paiements hypothécaires et
de le faire à temps et c'est quand même
une donnée qui est retardé donc six
turquie cela va prendre du temps si cela
devait se produire de voir une
augmentation du côté de délinquance il
faudrait davantage se pencher du côté
des délinquances des prêts hypothécaires
ou les autres produits de crédit les
prêts auto les prêts personnels par
exemple où là on commence à avoir une
légère hausse mais on est encore dans
des niveaux prépare dès qu'ils vont ce
que je comprends c'est que les canadiens
lorsqu'ils ont une pression sur leur
budget priorise le remboursement de leur
prêt hypothécaire un petit mot le très
rapidement en terminant il ya beaucoup
de prêteurs non traditionnels ils
prennent beaucoup de place encore elle
s'est en fait quand on regarde dans
l'ensemble du canada c'est à peu près 1
% du stock des prêts hypothécaires mais
ça peut varier beaucoup dépendamment des
régions très intéressante madame me
bourassa au choix merci beaucoup pour
vos explications merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]